The neat thing about linear
algebra in general is some
very seemingly simple concepts
can be interpreted in a bunch
of different ways, and can be
shown to represent different
ideas or different problems. And
that's what I'm going to
do in this video.
I'm going to explore the
nullspace, or even better, I'm
going to explore the
relationship-- if I have some
matrix A times some vector
x, and that that is
equal to the 0 vector.
And we, of course, saw on the
last few videos that the
nullspace of A, is equal to all
of the vectors x in Rn.
So this will have
n components.
This would have to be
an m by n matrix.
If this was an m by a matrix,
I'd say all of
the vectors in Ra.
So this number right here has to
be the same as that number
in order for the matrix vector
multiplication to be valid.
But the nullspace of A is all
of the vectors in Rn that
satisfy this equation.
Where if I take A and I multiply
it times any one of
the vectors in the nullspace,
I should get the 0 vector.
And this is going to have m
components, and we've seen
that in previous-- this is going
to have the 0 vectors.
I'll put it this way, the
0 vector's going to
be a member of Rm.
So that's what our
nullspace is.
Let's explore it a little bit.
We know already that our vector,
our matrix, can be
rewritten like this.
We could just write it as
a set of column vectors.
I could say this right here,
that's v1, then I'm going to
have v2, and I have n columns.
So this last column right here
is going to be v sub n.
So if I define my vectors this
way, that's the first vector,
that's the second vector, than
I can rewrite my matrix A.
I could say A is equal to just
a bunch of column vectors.
v1, v2, all the way to vn.
And multiplying this matrix
times a vector x, so times x,
so times x1, x2, all
the way to xn.
We've seen in the past on the
matrix vector product
definition video that this can
be interpreted as, this has
actually just coming straight
out of the definition.
This is the same thing as x1
times vector 1, times the
first column, plus x2 times the
second column, times that
column, all the way to, and you
just keep adding them up,
all the way to xn.
Times the nth column.
This just comes straight out
of our definition of matrix
vector products.
Now, if we're saying that Ax is
equal to 0, we're looking
for the solution set to that.
If we're looking for the
solution set to Ax is equal to
0, then that means-- is equal
to the 0 vector, that that
means that this sum, we're
trying to find a solution set
of this sum is equaling 0.
We want to figure out the x1's,
x2's, x3's, all the way
to xn's, that make this
equal the 0 vector.
What are we doing?
We're taking linear
combinations
of our column vectors.
We're taking linear combinations
of our column
vectors, and seeing if we can
take some linear combination
and get it to the 0 vector.
Now, this should start ringing
bells in your head.
This little equation, or this
little expression right here,
should start ringing bells.
This was part of how we
defined what linear
independence was.
We said that if this was the
definition of linear
independence, or we proved
this fell out of the
definition of linear
independence, and if I have a
bunch of vectors, v1, v2, all
the way to vn, we say that
they are linearly independent.
There's kind of the
non-mathematical way of
describing it, I guess this is
mathematical as well, is that
look, none of those vectors
can be represented as a
combination of the other ones.
And then we show that that means
that the only solution
to this equation would be
that x1, x2, all of the
coefficients on this, has
to be equal to 0.
That this is the
only solution.
Linear independence means that
this is the only solution to
this equation right now.
If the only way that you get
the 0 vector, by taking
combination of all of these
common vectors, the only way
to do that is to have all
of these guys equal 0.
Then you are linearly
independent.
Likewise, if v1, v2, all the
way to vn are linearly
independent, then the only
solution to this is for these
coefficients to be 0.
And we saw that in our video
on linear independence.
Now, if all of these
coefficients are 0,
what does that mean?
That means that our vector
x is the 0 vector,
and only the 0 vector.
That's the only solution.
So we have something
interesting here.
If our column vectors are
linearly independent, if v1,
v2, all the way to vn, are
linearly independent, then
that means that the only
solution to Ax equals 0, is
that x has to be equal
to 0 vector.
Or put another way, the solution
set of this equation,
which is really just a
nullspace, the nullspace is
all of the x's that satisfy
this equation.
So that the nullspace of A has
to only contain the 0 vector.
So that's an interesting
result.
If we're linearly independent,
then the nullspace of A only
contains the 0 vector.
Which is another way of saying
that-- let me write this--
well, I already wrote it down,
that x1, x2, all of them, have
to be equal to 0.
Now if I were to multiply this
equation out and get it into
reduced row echelon form,
what does that mean?
We saw in a previous video that
the nullspace of A is
equal to the nullspace of the
reduced row echelon form of A.
And that's-- the nullspace of
A is 0, because its column
vectors are each linearly
independent, and that means
that the nullspace of the
reduced row echelon form of A
must also equal the 0 vector.
And that means that if I take
the reduced row echelon form
of A, times-- maybe I'm being
a little redundant-- the
reduced row echelon form of A,
and I multiply that times x,
or I want to solve this
equation, the only solution
right here is x is equal
to the 0 vector.
And if you think about what
that means, if this is the
only solution, that means that
this reduced row echelon form
has no free variables.
It literally would just have
to look like this.
So this is x, x1, x2, all the
way to xn, the reduced row
echelon form of A, in order
for this to have a unique
solution, and that unique
solution being 0, the reduced
echelon form is going to
have to look like this.
1 times x1 plus 0 times all
the other ones, so you're
going to have just a bunch of
n0's, and you're going to have
1 times x2, plus 0's times
everything else.
And those 1's are going to go
all the way down the diagonal,
so it's going to look like that,
and then that is going
to be equal to the 0 vector.
And this is going to be a square
matrix, where this has
to be n, and this has to be n.
How do I know that?
Because I said that x1, x2, and
all of these have to be
equal to 0.
So they have to be equal to 0.
If I just write them as a system
of equations, if I
write x1 is equal to 0, x2 is
equal to 0, x3 is equal to 0,
all the way to xn
is equal to 0.
This system of equations, if
I wrote it as an augmented
matrix, remember this is
x1 plus 0, x2 plus 0.
This as in augmented matrix, and
we've done this multiple
times, it would look
like this.
1, you just have a bunch of 0's,
n0's, and then the 1's
would just go down the diagonal,
and then you'd have
n0's right there.
So that's where I'm
getting it from.
If we are linearly independent,
the nullspace of
A is going to be just a 0
vector, and if the nullspace
of A is just a 0 vector, then
the nullspace of the reduced
row echelon form is
only the 0 vector.
The only solution is all
of the x's equal to 0.
Which means a reduced row
echelon form of A has to
essentially just be 1's down
the diaganol, with 0's
everywhere else.
So anyway, I just want to make
this-- this is kind of a neat
by-product of an
interpretation of the nullspace.
Let me write that.
Let me summarize our results.
The nullspace of A, if it just
equals 0, then that means, you
can go both ways, that's true
if and only if the column
vectors of A are linearly
independent.
And all of that's only true--
this is true, I was going to
do a triangle, it might turn
into a square-- if x1, x2, all
of these have to be equal 0.
This is the only solution.
And then that implies that the
reduced row echelon, and I
didn't do it as precisely as
I would have liked, but the
reduced row echelon form of A
is essentially going to be a
square n by n matrix.
And, by the way, this can only
be true if we're dealing with
an n by n matrix
to begin with.
And maybe I'll do that a little
bit more precisely in a
future video.
But then the reduced row echelon
form of A is going to
have to look like this, just
a bunch of 1's down the
diagonal, with 0's
everywhere else.
And these all imply
each other.
Now, what if the nullspace of A
contains some other vectors?
Well, then we would have to say
that the column vectors of
A are linearly dependent.
And if they're linearly
dependent, then we wouldn't
have a reduced row echelon form
of A that looked like
this, you would have something
that would have some free
variables that allows you to
create more solutions there.
But anyway, I just wanted to
give you this angle on how you
can interpret the nullspace and
how it relates to linear
Independence.